all right for all you digital powers in
the house here comes the part of the
night where we talk about blowing stuff
up when you yeah they get when you think
of destruction Stanford University isn't
the first place that comes to mind but
that is exactly where fizz Bam a physics
based simulation engine got its start
his bomb was previously awarded for its
use in fluid simulation but this award
is for a separate module focused on
rigid body dynamics rigid bodies are as
they sound solid objects like buildings
and cars and bridges using rigid body
dynamics and integrating the phys BAM
engine ILM engineered a destruction
system complete with artist controls and
production toolset one of the earliest
destruction tool sets in town ILM epic
work with fizzbin was most recently seen
in the flattening of san francisco by a
dreadnought class starship for the film
star trek into darkness that's actually
twice the size of a constitution class
starship so that's that's like serious
you know it I'm saying - Bryce Criswell
and Ron fedko for the development of the
ILM fizz BAM destruction system the
Academy presents a technical achievement
award congratulations
oh my gosh it's such an honor so I want
to say thank you to the Academy and the
investigating committee for recognizing
our work our system epitomizes the union
of technical how-to and artistic talent
and for the artists at ILM who use our
system I thank you for every building
you broke every wall you smashed and
every vehicle you destroyed I want to
thank my family my wonderful wife Kari
for all your support throughout the
years these systems do not come together
easily and so you know without your
patience and your encouragement I would
not be here today
I want to thank Ron fed to you for being
my mentor and my advocate throughout the
years and of course Rachel and Frank
Peterson my clenteen Jeff Smith just to
name a few of the very talented artists
that help work on this system thank you
we should all thank Margo and Myles for
coming
mr. fantastic gave me my award and that
note I'll thank all the super villains
and giant robots that like to destroy
stuff keeps us in business and I think
my daughter's Brittany and Brianna for
coming
my 11 year old is working her way
through her Java programming book right
now and this helps her get more done